[Musique]
bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7-8 choisir
vos idées sorties dans le département on
commence ensuite avec le sommaire des
bonbons ou un sort une formule que vous
entendrez forcément ce lundi pour
halloween à france miniature les
monstres sont déjà là ils attendent les
visiteurs pour une quête à la recherche
de légendes oubliées et que serait
halloween semble ses citrouilles dans
votre chronique dédiée aux juniors
mélanie poker nous donnera quelques
conseils pour sculpter votre lanterne
enfin spectacle de magie théâtralisée a
retrouvé à versailles maurice audin met
en scène la vie du plus grand tricheur
de tous les temps poker et escroc une
ambiance casino au coeur de la cité
royale
halloween c'est ce lundi comme chaque
année la fête la plus effrayante se
déroule à la veille de la toussaint le
31 octobre et pour cette occasion les
monstres et autres fantômes sont de
sortie certains ont déjà investi le parc
de france miniature nicolas landry est
allé leur jeter un sort
la gargouille comment vas-tu sadaoui et
bien voyait une gargouille comme
compagnon de visites des géants qui vous
surveille et une guide aux oreilles
pointues pour halloween les monstres se
sont invitées à france miniature des
personnages plus ou moins effrayant qui
déambulent à la rencontre des passants
ça faisait pas trop peur au début on
avait un peu peur parce que c'était la
première fois et à la fin ça allait
mieux j'ai bien
et j'ai eu un peu peur j'ai trouvé ça
sympa c'était original
les acteurs sont sont marrants et je
pense que les petites ont bien eu peur
c'était sympa la sorcière à cacher des
histoires dans les différentes régions
de france les visiteurs partent donc à
la recherche des contes perdus sur le
chemin ils doivent résoudre des énigmes
pour retrouver les mythes je suis
rien sans la lumière je suis aussi
l'obscurité je suis dans chacun de tes
pas le petit chinois jouent avec moi qui
suis-je c'est vraiment une création
originale
sur ce parc là est une création
qui permet aussi aux gens de découvrir
des histoires un peu inconnu car la
france est vrai regorge vraiment de
d'histoires et de légendes et ses formes
est là dessus la quête se termine à
paris la gargouille à trouver quelque
chose
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il s'agit de la légende de jean
l'écorcheur assassiné par catherine de
médicis en 15 164 on raconte que son
fantôme serait revenu tourmenter les
nuits de la reine les monstres eu entre
le parc jusqu'à la toussaint
[Musique]
au château de thoiry les morts
reviennent aussi à la vie pour halloween
le site se transforme en scène de crime
les 30 et 31 octobre demeure parties
sont organisées un meurtre a été commis
au château et les participants doivent
gagner des épreuves pour récolter des
indices afin de démasquer le meurtrier
on écoute tiphaine de la rivière l'art
et la responsable culturel du château de
nous en dire plus sur cette enquête
c'est comme un grand cluedo géant
d'halloween donc qui va y avoir un
meurtre au départ au château et les gens
sont par équipes et donc par équipes
vont devoir à les démasquer le coupable
de la soirée c'est sur le thème
d'halloween mais le principe de la
soirée c'est vraiment le jeu le jeu en
équipe il ya des épreuves chaque
personnage fait passer une petite
épreuve
si on l'a réussi on a un indice si on ne
réussit pas on n'a pas lundi donc c'est
vraiment cohésion d'équipé puis pour
jouer tous ensemble
ce sont des personnages qui ont vécu au
château et a longtemps donc ça pouvait
être au xviie au xviiie siècle et donc
on retrouve l'ancien cuisinière du
château qui est morte il ya 200 ans on
retrouve le palefrenier le forgeron
enfin voilà donc des personnages qui ont
vécu dans l'ancien temps
[Musique]
ils ont 14 suspects à aller voir donc
chacun des quatorze personnages est
susceptible d'être le coupable
et donc les épreuves je peux pas tout
vous dévoiler mais où des jeux de
réflexion des énigmes ou des choses à
faire ou à manger un bon insectes free
c'est bon pour la croissance ça fait
cinq ans qu'on l'organisé
j'espère encore pour de nombreuses
années mais qu'est ce qu'il ya sous les
tombes
des morts
mais bon le soir d'halloween on
accueille environ 130 140 participants
qui sont répartis en deux équipes et ils
font côté à peu près deux heures en tout
donc tout le parcours dans les jardins
et dans le château qui se termine par
une petite collation mais bien vas-y va
nous voir va donc voir ce qu'il y a dans
le trou
y at il quelque chose
est-ce que tu aperçois quelque chose ou
alors au château ça marche toujours bien
les adultes sont très demandeurs de
soirée de jeu on a un tarif c'est un
tarif unique à 29 euros par personne et
les gens qui sont détenteurs de
passeports pour le parc de thoiry ou un
tarif réduit on conseille aux ados
adultes on n'en prend pas de jeunes
enfants va y avoir des énigmes à
résoudre
si vous vous l'avez sortir vivant du
château
il ressent encore vraiment quelques
dernières places il faut nous appeler
hochettes gens se déguisent et
d'ailleurs depuis ce sera la deuxième
année qu'on remet le trophée du meilleur
costume masculin et féminin à la fin de
la soirée donc tout le monde
ne le fait pas mais s'est fortement
conseillé alors moi je suis la gardienne
du château puisque je surveille un petit
peu tout ce petit monde que tout se
passe bien et effectivement je suis
déguisé pour que passer inaperçu mais
mes yeux sont là
[Musique]
on poursuit notre page spéciale
halloween avec une activité à faire chez
vous mais à l'époque et à tester la
sculpture de citrouilles elle va nous
expliquer bonjour mélanie bonjour
qu'allié alors c'est même la rédaction
qui m'a lancé un défi montrer mes
talents de sculptrice de citrouille le
décor indispensable à halloween j'en
avais jamais fait je me suis donc rendu
à la ferme de gally parce qu'il propose
chaque année des ateliers pour réaliser
ses propres citoyens et donc premier
secret que vous allez nous dévoiler
comment est ce qu'on l'a choisi l'un
déjà tout dépend du résultat que l'on
veut donner les grosses citrouilles sont
conseillés pour les citrouilles qui font
peur
les petites c'est plus pour les plus
jeunes et celles qui sont allongés c'est
pour faire des citrouilles rigolote et
séguillon d'alors d'abord avant de
conseiller ou vidal il faut savoir qu'il
faut avoir des outils et les outils
indispensables voire les réaliser
écoutez guillaume vidal des fermes de
gally qui me les donne c'est le propre
des citrouilles d'aller voir un bon
couteau avec son dans alors un couteau
tout lise pour beaucoup plus précis une
bonne cuillère ils font aussi des
cuillères tout fait pour racler l'instar
de la citrouille
des gants c'est pas mal et un peu de
courage un peu de courage il faut un peu
de courage un petit peu l'idée c'est
quand même de se faire plaisir et de
créer bien sûr il citera qui nous plaît
mais il faut savoir que la chair de la
citrouille peut être un peu dur on peut
le faire dès 3 ans malgré tout mais
toujours en présence d'un adulte pour le
faire seuls les équipes de gally
conseille d'attendre 12 13 ans faire une
citrouille s'apprend bonne demi heure
une fois qu'on a tous les instruments on
peut se lancer écoutez alors le but du
jeu ça va être d'abord de d'ouvrir le
chapeau après le chapon peut faire son
insert pour aller beaucoup plus vite
mais après en soit on y trouvait un peu
plus esthétique elle nous empêche de
faire une belle étoile autour à peu près
régulière est comme ça à prendre
meilleure satisfaction comme les
résultats ça fait un peu des cheveux à
la citrouille ce qui est important c'est
de faire attention quand on enlève le
chapeau de la citrouille des fois ne
veut pas venir et on risque de casser du
coup la petite l'aptitude de la
citrouille le pédoncule alors on peut
s'aider de la cuillère le mange de la
cuillère et
essayer de faire un levier avec
pour éviter de casser justement le
pédoncule de la citrouille
ça a l'air un peu compliqué quand même
ans a pas l'air si avait donc ça pas
tant que ça je vais vous avouer comme
c'était ma toute première citrouille
j'ai pas osé y aller vraiment j'avais
vraiment peur de l'abîmer donc je
n'avais pas assez coupé j'avais pas
enfoncé monkoto assez profondément donc
le coût de la cuillère je vous le
confirme ça aide vraiment bien et une
fois le chapeau au lever on passe au
grattage de l'intérieur alors pour
savoir pour faciliter le grattage il
faut faire un chapeau à ses larges ce
que je n'ai pas fait donc c'était un peu
plus compliqué les petites mains ce qui
est mon cas ça peut aider aussi et une
fois propre on passe bien sûr à la
sculpture le plus important écoutez on
applique maintenant à choisir la forme
que la citrouille la voir or d'abord on
part sur l'esprit est ce qu'on veut une
citrouille plutôt kg soit effrayante
plutôt rigolote et en fonction de ça on
peut dessiner les yeux le nez si on veut
mettre un nez et surtout la bouche qui
est très importante plus on va avoir une
bouche assez grande puis on va voir du
coup la lumière qui va passer faut aussi
penser la lumière donc si on fait des
tout petits yeux on n'aura pas beaucoup
de lumière alors il ya deux styles deux
citrouilles différentes vous quelles
sont les principales différences entre
ces deux styles a rejeté cette à l'heure
il ya les rigolades il ya celles qui
font un peu plus peur on va le voir sur
les images et l'animateur guillaume a
lui choisi la citrouille effrayante donc
il a créé des formes pointues de mon
côté je fais la petite fille sage j'ai
préféré faire une citrouille rigolote
donc j'ai fait des formes plus arrondies
pour les moins confiants il est moins
douée en dessin ce qui était mon cas on
peut aussi dessiner un modèle au feutre
et après on découpe à nouveau on va
parler de sécurité on ne met pas ses
mains à l'intérieur de la citrouille
parce que s'ils écoutent oric on peut se
faire mal le maître mot par contre ne
pas oublier c'est de se faire plaisir
vous pouvez jouer sur les faons vous
pouvez jouer sur les expressions mais
aussi transparent si vous enlevez que la
peau ou un peu moins de chair et puis on
finit avec bien sûr l'ingrédient
indispensable la bougie pour faire de la
lumière qu'elle mais j'espère vous allez
nous faire faire ma montre mais je vais
sûrement me lancer mais ne sais pas si
jean fred est aussi jolie on va les
montrer quand même parce qu'on en a du
coup une petite qui est plus dans
l'esprit voilà enfants amusement qui
fait un peu moins peur alors là par
contre on en a une énorme jeu passif et
réussir à la sauver mais voilà celle ci
ça c'est vraiment de la laci trou de
compétition sur wes assez déjà des
prouesses et il a l'image l'amène elle
était loin d'être aussi bien réussi
quand même merci beaucoup en tout cas
mélanie pour ses conseils aussi vous ne
l'est pas si vous n'osez pas le faire
seul la ferme pédagogique de gally vous
propose des ateliers jusqu'au 31 octobre
on quitte l'univers d'halloween pour
celui de l'illusion maurice duda
magicien et cartman est en
représentation ce soir et demain à
versailles son spectacle la dap adapte
librement l'histoire vraie de richard
marcus le plus grands tricheurs de jeux
d'argent de tous les temps un one man
show entre théâtre et magie inspiré de
l'univers des casinos regardez
on peut regrouper sur la streif
la carte aux magies maurice duda en a
fait sa spécialité pour son spectacle
l'illusionniste devient richard marcus
maître de la triche aux jeux d'argent
une histoire où se mêlent magie il est
humain encore perdu vous savez la nuit à
las vegas dans le désert
il ya des tas de trous dans le désert
et il ya des tas de problèmes d'enterrer
dans ces trous
rouges c'est un as on sait sa vie dans
les grandes lignes mais ç'a été romancés
et bien sûr le support magique c'est à
dire les tours de magie sont là juste
pour étayer le propos pour illustrer
l'histoire ça a été mise en scène comme
un road movie en fait à la scorsese pas
donc si nos téléspectateurs connaissent
les films casino auchan dit leeuwen
voilà on est on est dans tout cet esprit
là c'est un spectacle de magie théâtre à
dix durant 25 ans richard marcus a
amassé plus de 5 millions de dollars
grâce à ces techniques muni d'un simple
jeu de cartes il joue manipule et
démontre ses méthodes avec une dextérité
envoûtante une passion pour la
discipline commencé à l'âge de 10 ans
j'ai découvert les magiciens la
télévision avec josé garcia mort avec
avec gérard majax avec avec touche tous
ces magiciens la de l'époque et puis
ensuite il ya eu il ya eu gilles arthur
il ya eu bernard il ya eu bernard bilis
j'ai découvert et qui a été le gros
déclic pour moi ça fait rêver et canton
à la fibre en principe on ne lâche pas
pendant plus d'une heure maurice duda
vous plonge au coeur de la capitale
mondiale du poker ses casinos et ces
escrocs richard marcus et sa légende
sont à découvrir jusqu'au 29 octobre
un rendez vous à noter ce week end dans
vos agendas le château de breteuil
invite les grenadiers de napoléon tout
le week-end pour un défilé un campement
sera reconstitué les visiteurs pourront
découvrir les armes et les traditions de
l'époque l'animation est accessible sans
supplément sur le prix des visites c'est
la fin de ce set 8 loisirs merci de nous
avoir suivis je vous retrouve vendredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro 10 il a
très bon week-end à tous
[Musique]